this area and what happened here long
ago is what Maria hides behind the
astral Clocktower this is the fishing
hamlet the third and final stage of
blood bonds DLC beneath the surface off
to the left and the right is the city of
yharnam the nightmare we progress
through from this perspective at least
resided beneath the great lake all along
which explains why all the patients in
the previous episode heard the dripping
and the currents and the rain I went
through the footage actually because I
was curious and just before the clock
tower opened both hands aligned on one
of the many runes that line the edges of
the clock guess which one it was they
pointed to a deep sea rune it reads this
transcription of the great ones in human
voices
depicts down reaching currents this rune
means deep sea great volumes of water
serve as a bulwark guarding sleep and an
augur of the eldritch truth overcome
this hindrance and seek what is yours
the truths hidden here have to do with
the Bergen worth scholars who violated
this small fishing village long ago
Berman was black and blasphemous
London's blood-crazed fiends
tournament for the wrenches by the rat
of mother cos mercy for the poor wasn't
child mercy oh please there's a lot in
this dialogue firstly this inhabitant of
the village had some interaction with
the scholars of Bergen worth the
wretches as he calls them the murderers
the blood-crazed fiends they did
something to a child and he calls upon
the wrath of mother calls whose name
should probably be familiar to you
right sunshine cousin there you hear
friends clearly she's a great one as
recommended by a couple of people in the
last video if you come here as a piece
of cauliflower then instead the villager
says this curse here curse there a curse
by he and she why care a bottomless
curse a bottomless sea source of all
greatness all things that be listen for
the baneful chants weep with them as one
in trance and we with us oh wait was us
so what did those of Bergen worth do to
warrant curses being placed upon them it
must have been pretty terrible and the
accursed brew reads skull of a local
from the violated fishing village the
inside of the skull was forcibly
searched for eyes as evidenced by the
innumerable scratches and indentations
no wonder the skull became stewed in
curses and this skull partly explains it
it sounds like the scholars of Bergen
worth came to this little village and
violated the inhabitants in the name of
new discoveries and it also sounds like
the villagers called upon a great one to
curse the scholars according to the moon
rune the great ones are sympathetic in
spirit after all and based on the way
the Boggan Worth scholars were violating
them and searching them for eyes clearly
the villagers had had some interaction
with the eldritch truth so the scholars
were cursed and so were their successors
the hunters at this point I went back
and I unlocked all the cells we found in
Episode one do you remember those they
were just past Ludwig according to this
key hunters are held within the
underground cells so that things better
left unseen and better left unknown will
decay quietly within the first few cells
we find this church pick hunter he drops
the church pick which is a sort of
pickaxe crossed with a short sword or a
spear type thing and I also unlocked the
door that held this guy who was reciting
something about being a true blade of
the church according to the wikis his
only purpose is to be killed and looted
for his set which names him as Yamamura
the wanderer in eastern warrior who
pursued a beast for honorable revenge
and then became a hunter of the league
the innermost cell belonging to the
bellringer remains locked for now
fear the bells toll for only death
awaits foolish prying eyes and the
church assassins are never far behind
clearly there's more to discover so now
that the stage is set let's play our
part and get through to the finale I
love how this stage feels like an actual
fishing village they've done a great job
with that it's a unique location for a
level as far as the souls born series
goes and they do so much with such a
simple theme the fish men are a dime a
dozen and I like how backstabs are
actually a viable technique against them
unlike most enemies in blood-borne up
until this point the fish men attack in
packs and they serve as the standard
enemy but the real threat are the giant
fish troll things the most scary enemy
in my opinion is the one that can outrun
your player character and just look at
how this thing moves when I turn my back
on it it scared the [ __ ] out of me right
there approximately 1,000 backstabs
later you learn just how difficult these
things are maybe I should have used
those obviously placed fire pots against
it hmm a note for next time
hidden on the cliff face also is a path
back to the ladder that was in front of
the starting lantern the player who pays
attention is more likely to have checked
for a hidden path back which is a nice
touch and it is pretty worth it to look
around all the time look at this thing I
nope doubt of here pretty quick I didn't
really fancy one of those things
attacking me on a ladder and I have to
say again I really like the way this bit
is designed I only looked around because
I started to hear the winter lanterns
singing and that's the kind of sound you
want to watch out for and it rewarded me
by telling me there's a giant fish troll
on the roof you guys are probably
realizing that I really like when games
reward the observant player I've
probably said that a lot of times by now
so this next thing that happened
probably happened to all of you guys too
right you start fighting one of the fish
trolls and you know you convince
yourself that other one on the roof is
gonna come attack me that's not gonna
happen and then you're about to win and
you're like hang on what's that noise
goddammit
one of these things was tough enough but
- I ran away and I got up the ladder
just in time and I was gonna plan my
next attack and then I fell in don't
worry I survived until I got out and
then I was like I know I'll drop those
rope Molotov cocktails behind me they
can fall down ladders right then no
turns out they can't and then I fell in
again and at this point I just made
plunging attacks a part of my strategy
it didn't work really eventually I just
got good and I realized to my surprise
that one of them had dropped a weapon it
was the rakuyo which is Maria's weapon
it reads hunter weapon wielded by lady
Maria of the astral Clocktower a trick
sword originating in the same country as
the cainhurst chikage only this sword
feeds not off blood but instead demands
great dexterity lady Maria was fond of
this aspect of the rakuyo as she frowned
upon blood blades being a distant
relative of the Queen one day she
abandoned her beloved rakuyo casting it
into a dark well when she could stomach
it no longer what a neat little story
Maria must have eventually given in to
her desire for blood as she certainly
uses blood and self-sacrifice in her
boss fight how curious that she's
related to Queen Annalise as well I've
got some theories on this but it'll have
to wait for prepare to cry by the end of
the play through the rakuyo becomes my
main weapon this is a skill build after
all
using the blades of Mercy the burial
blade and not to mention this character
actually looks just like Maria right I
modeled this character after the doll
ages ago
so yeah who would have thought that that
would pay off it's cool to have a weapon
that you can call your own you know I've
been searching for one for a while and
mine is the rakuyo what's yours you
should let me know in a hut further down
we find
plantain and lying on the ground dying
next to that lantern is Simon the bow
blade hunter oh you
I'm afraid I've made a bunch of things I
can hear the bell now the beasts hide
assassin he's after me again and again
it never ends
ah please I need you to do something
this village is the true secret
testament to the old sins
it feeds this hunters nightmare please
bring to an end the horror
so our forefathers sin we hunters cannot
bear their weight forever it isn't fair
it just isn't fair
Simon was one of the last Saint hunters
in the nightmare he pushed us to go
deeper and deeper into it and with Maria
gone he seems like he decided to come
forward himself and fight a little bit
farther however there is another hunter
here other than Simon someone who
doesn't want anyone discovering what
lies at the end of the nightmare Brad or
the church assassin the weapon he uses
is the blood letter which assumes it's
true and terrifying form after it draws
upon blood from the inner reaches of
one's body and soul this is what it
reads this was the only effective method
of expelling tainted blood also Brad or
isolated in his cell continued to
believe well look who's here welcome to
my quarters
I've never entertained a guest before
are you going to kill me after all you
done kill me as if to right your wrongs
you get his weapon if you kill him but I
kept Brad all alive here because I
wasn't sure if there was more to him and
sure enough he does invade you a total
of four times throughout the rest of the
stage once outside his cell once on a
bridge once in ambush when you pick up
an item down below and once in a cave
each time he drops a different piece of
his attire the clothing has its own
story as well
turns out Bray door was a church
assassin who wore the beasts hide of his
former compatriots the church gave him a
bell that he could ring to hunt people
down and stop people discovering their
secrets and we'll talk more about him
later but moving on in the next section
I spied one of those mollusk things
clinging to a post and I was like yeah
I'm not going to let myself get ambushed
by that thing
I still remembered how one of them fell
on me in an earlier level and then I was
like worried about looking upwards and
hundreds of them crawled out of shells
and ambushed me and I felt pretty stupid
but seriously do you remember that first
one that fell out of the sky in Episode
one it makes sense now doesn't it all
along there was this world above us we
just didn't have the insight to see it
and how this one fell out of the
nightmare itself is beyond me but it's a
cool concept to think that all of these
nightmares are layered it makes me think
about the ship masts all over the ocean
as we progress think about it you've
actually seen these ship masts before
you can actually see them in the
nightmare frontier suggesting that
there's water down there hidden in the
fog or perhaps that the nightmare
frontier is even connected to this
nightmare but is even higher up after
all in the first stage of the DLC
there's an amygdala corpse as well
perhaps it fell out of the nightmare
frontier as well this is really
speculation but interesting to think
about to quote the cosmic I watch a
badge here we stand feet planted in the
earth but might the cosmos be very near
us only just above our heads all of the
nightmare realms are really high up and
they all have great ones residing at
some of their highest points at land
masses float in the nightmare frontier
with mojo in his loft in the tallest
tower the hunters dream is nestled
amongst these arched tree looking things
in the clouds with the moon presence
descending from above and the hunters
nightmare is within a great ocean below
a grand lake of mud and on the beach of
said Lake is the washed-up corpse of a
great one that was discovered long ago
born from this corpse is the orphan of
cause how curious that the orphans
mother wasn't alive for the birth it
reminds me of how the moon presence must
die for us to be born into great ones
well
this is probably one of the hardest
bosses in blood-borne the orphan is
insanely quick he has a hugely varied
moveset and he even has a second phase
where he evolves into a butterfly
looking thing the neat little
observations in this fight are that he's
fighting you with the placenta that
trailed out with him when he was born
and also that mother calls herself has a
face turns out she's somewhat humanoid
in form just like he is and I actually
can't help myself I start talking about
gameplay and then I get pulled back to
talking about the lore again I kind of
figure that you guys are realizing how
good the gameplay has been for the most
part in this level it's been an amazing
stage but let's just roll with it let's
just talk about the story while I show
you some of my failed fights against
this guy specifically let's talk about
why our character is here why we're
doing all of this we do have most of the
items and dialogue now after all in the
dialogue at the start we learned that
the Bergen worth Scholars stumbled upon
this fishing village and that they did
some pretty terrible things not only did
they violate the villages themselves as
mentioned in the accursed brew
description but they must have also
stumbled upon the great one cause or her
corpse at least which washed up on the
shore because they managed to get
themselves cursed the man at the start
of the village and even the woman
speaking as you get pulled into the dlc
remember her both of them plead for
curses to be placed upon the fiends upon
their children and their children's
children on man and woman alike a
bottomless curse a curse forever true
and the great ones do have the power to
curse people according to the defiled
chalice which is an item a lot of us
probably have forgotten about curses are
and I quote caused by inciting the anger
of the great ones
additionally according to the Moon rune
as I've mentioned the great ones are
sympathetic and spirit so it's not crazy
to think that a great
may have listened to the inhabitants of
the fishing village as they pleaded for
the Bergen worth scholars to be cursed
in return for violating their village
the curse means that the Bergen worth
scholars and eventually their successors
the hunters would be drawn into a
hunter's nightmare
upon death and it's a pretty perfect
curse when you think about it it's like
the great one is saying oh you like
hunting so much well live here forever
and hunt for all eternity
then Simon tells us that the village is
the source of the sin and implies that
we can bring an end to the curse here so
we do what a hunter does best we hunt
ah
sweet child of course returns to the
ocean a bottomless curse a bottomless
sea accepting of all that is and can be
when you get back to the hunter's dream
the doll will tell you that both she and
gomen sense that they've somehow been
freed from their shackles this happens
to the doll and Gherman when you kill
Maria and the orphan respectively I'm
starting to understand how they're
connected to these creatures but it is
still really weird that they can sense
their counterparts in the nightmare I'm
still trying to figure it out hell I
personally haven't even got this
dialogue yet because the doll doesn't
give you the dialogue if the dream is on
fire which is annoying I'll have to play
through again so I can show it to you
but so much to talk about here there's a
million other things I want to talk to
you guys about there's even another boss
in this DLC that I don't have time to
include but mostly I really want to talk
to you guys about the law still this DLC
revealed a ton about the timeline it
reveals a lot about how Nightmare realms
work and it's raised even more questions
that I myself haven't answered it's
expanded the stories of gurmann of
Michael ash of Lawrence and the doll and
all of those videos will be coming soon
I promise I could rush the law stuff out
for views but I do want to do it
properly so thank you for subscribing
and waiting and I reckon it's best to do
it right the first time I also have to
thank you guys for supporting this
three-part series so well I didn't think
a playthrough would go down so amazingly
but it did and I really appreciate all
the likes and views and the thousands
and thousands of comments I love telling
stories and I enjoyed telling my own
story about my playthrough and my
observations and it was really cool to
read yours in the comments as well you
guys Rock let's do it again sometime
and also lastly a special thanks to all
the patrons that support me over on
patreon you've made it possible for me
to do this full-time now and
you're incredible and thank you for
changing my life I'll see you in the
next one cheers guys